tenemos una mini nave espacial llena de
extraterrestres han terminado de
investigar un nuevo satélite que está
lleno de nuevas formas de vida pero como
ya terminaron de investigar se van a ir
van a regresar a casa para platicarle a
sus amigos todo lo que han descubierto
digamos que en algún momento cuando
están ascendiendo se están moviendo a
cuatro metros por segundo y como son
extraterrestres pequeñitos su nave solo
pesa 2.9 kilogramos pero ellos tienen
que saber si van a poder salir de este
satélite o no y tienen que poner
atención a su rapidez pero en lugar de
estar viendo un velocímetro estos
extraterrestres inteligentes usan un
diagrama de tiempo contra fuerza en su
panel de control tienen un diagrama de
fuerza contra tiempo que les dice cuál
es su fuerza neta y no es cualquier
fuerza esta es entonces la fuerza neta
que actúa en la nave es la fuerza total
que viene de los cohetes de la nave de
la gravedad de este satélite y de
cualquier otra fuerza que esté actuando
en la nave sin duda tienen sensor
y avanzados para detectar todas las
fuerzas así que les da la fuerza meta
con respecto al tiempo pero ellos se
preguntan cuál será su velocidad después
nueve segundos y esta es la lectura que
les da y ahora pueden determinar esta
velocidad y lo van a hacer
así están viendo que tienen una fuerza
de 3 newtons que va a estar actuando
durante 4 segundos así que aquí tienen
una fuerza constante de 3 newtons
durante 4 segundos y cualquier
extraterrestre que viaje por el espacio
sabe que la fuerza neta multiplicada por
el intervalo de tiempo en el que se
aplica la fuerza va a ser igual al
impulso pero no cualquier impulso este
es el impulso neto así que si ponemos
aquí nuestra fuerza neta de 3 newtons
multiplicada por el intervalo de tiempo
que es de 4 segundos nos va a quedar 12
newtons segundo y me pueden decir a mí
para que me sirve este 12 newton
segundos y yo lo que quiero conocer es
la velocidad y además la velocidad
después de 9 segundos pero
en la academia de viajes espaciales nos
enseñan que no solamente la fuerza neta
por el intervalo del tiempo es igual al
impulso neto
esto también es igual al cambio en el
momento del objeto en el que se está
ejerciendo la fuerza y esto es bueno ya
que conocemos la masa del objeto y
queremos saber algo sobre su velocidad
sabemos que el momento es m por b y nos
ayudamos de esto para encontrar lo que
nos interesa pero estos 12 newton
segundo solo fueron para los primeros 4
segundos como encuentro el impulso para
los siguientes 3 segundos
vemos que durante los siguientes 3
segundos esta fuerza no es constante va
disminuyendo como encuentro esto sigue
mi valor de fuerza no es constante
aquí ya no puedo simplemente multiplicar
la fuerza por el tiempo ya que esta
fuerza va cambiando aquí vamos a hacer
un truco fíjense que aquí arriba usamos
estos tres newtons de fuerza y los
multiplicamos por el tiempo que fue de 4
segundos
realmente lo que hicimos fue tomar la
altura de este rectángulo y multiplicar
la por la base de este rectángulo lo que
nos da el área de este rectángulo aquí
encontramos el área bajo la curva y esto
nos da el impulso y esto no es
casualidad el impulso lo encontramos
como el área bajo la curva de una
gráfica de fuerza contra tiempo y esto
es extremadamente útil porque ahora que
tengo un área en donde la fuerza está
variando con el simple hecho de
encontrar el área bajo esta curva vamos
a tener el impulso el impulso es igual
al área bajo la curva en un diagrama de
fuerza neta contra tiempo y al decir
área bajo la curva nos referimos a esta
línea que es nuestra curva
el área que forma con respecto a este
eje horizontal que en este caso este eje
horizontal es el tiempo vamos a hacerlo
ya encontramos el impulso para esta
sección y ahora vamos a encontrar el
impulso para esta otra sección muy bien
vamos a encontrar el impulso neto y este
es un triángulo así que vamos a tener un
medio por la base que es 123 segundos
multiplicada por la altura que sigue
siendo de 3 newtons
esto nos queda 3 por 3 9 entre 2 es
igual a 4.5 newtons segundos
este es nuestro impulso neto en esta
sección pero nos queda un área más y
esta área pues está extraña porque ahora
se encuentra por debajo del eje éste
sigue siendo un triángulo pero como aquí
tenemos fuerzas negativas esto va a ser
un impulso neto negativo si mi área está
por encima del eje voy a tener un
impulso positivo y si mi área está por
debajo del eje entonces mi impulso va a
ser negativo y aunque sea un impulso
negativo vamos a seguir calculando el
área sigue siendo el área de un
triángulo porque esto es un medio la
base es de 2 segundos
y la altura es de menos 2 newtons y esto
es igual a 2
newton segundo y ahora si ya podemos
encontrar cuál es la velocidad de mi
nave espacial después de los 9 segundos
y esto es suponiendo que esta medición
comenzó cuando el tiempo era igual a 0
segundos que fue en este momento en el
que se tenía en los 4 metros por segundo
y con esto podemos decir que el impulso
neto
es igual al cambio total del momento en
esta nave y podemos encontrar el impulso
neto al sumar todos los impulsos que
encontramos vamos a sumar estos 12
newtons por segundo de la primera
sección los primeros 4 segundos y a esto
le vamos a sumar los 4.5 newton segundos
que encontramos de los 4 a los 7
segundos y finalmente le vamos a agregar
los menos que aquí se me estaba
olvidando poner el menos que horror
así es como luego uno se equivoca y
reprueba los exámenes sumamos estos
menos 2 newton segundos también para
obtener el impulso neto total y si
sumamos los 12 newton segundos más los
4.5 newton segundos menos los 2 newton
segundos nos va a dar que esto es igual
a 14.5 newton segundo positivo lo que es
bueno para nuestros amigos
extraterrestres ya que necesitan salir d
satélite y necesitan un impulso positivo
ahora encontremos cuál es el cambio en
el momento nosotros sabemos que delta p
es igual a el momento final menos el
momento inicial esto lo podemos escribir
como masa por velocidad final menos masa
por velocidad inicial ahora si éste
fueron cohete terrestre esto sería
difícil ya que los cohetes terrestres
expulsan combustible con una proporción
muy grande en la parte de atrás al menos
usando la tecnología terrestre por lo
que pierden masa y entonces su masa va a
disminuir los cohetes terrestres
expulsan combustible hacia abajo para
poder impulsarse hacia arriba pero si
perdemos masa esta masa no va a
permanecer constante haciendo que este
proceso sea más difícil ya que la masa
final va a ser distinta a la masa
inicial quizás de aquí viene la frase de
esto no es ciencia de cohetes ya que las
de cohetes si es difícil pero esta
tecnología extraterrestre va a expulsar
solo un poquito de masa y en cambio va a
tener un gran momento va a tener mucha
velocidad cuando expulsa un poquitito de
masa así que casi no inyectan
combustible y lo poquito que inyectan
les va a dar mucha velocidad por lo que
casi no pierden masa lo que nos permite
resolver este problema suponiendo que la
masa es constante
esto me queda que es igual a mas 14.5
newtons segundos y esto es igual aquí
tengo la masa en ambos lados así que la
puedo factorizar esto me queda igual a
la masa por la velocidad final menos la
velocidad inicial esto es igual a 2.9
kilogramos que es la masa multiplicada
por la velocidad final la velocidad
final a los 9 segundos porque yo sume
todos los impulsos para encontrar el
impulso neto total
para ese tiempo - mi velocidad inicial
que fue de 4 metros por segundo y aquí
voy a hacer un poquito más de espacio ya
que necesito seguir haciendo cuentas ok
entonces quiero la velocidad final voy a
dividir ambos lados de esta igualdad
entre 2.9 kilogramos por lo que me va a
quedar 5 positivo
newton segundos entre kilogramo que es
igual a metros por segundo y esto va a
ser igual a mi velocidad final menos la
velocidad inicial de 4 metros por
segundo y ahora para obtener mi
velocidad final voy a sumar 4 metros por
segundo en ambos lados y me va a quedar
lo pongo para aquí que mi velocidad
final es igual a 9 metros por segundo
así que después de 9 segundos la
velocidad va a ser de 9 metros por
segundo que es una coincidencia numérica
en resumen lo que hicimos aquí fue
encontrar el área bajo la curva ya que
el área bajo la curva en un diagrama
de fuerza contra tiempo nos da el
impulso encontramos el área bajo la
curva de todo este intervalo tomando en
cuenta que las áreas que se encuentran
por debajo del eje van a ser negativas
sumamos todos nuestros impulsos para
encontrar el impulso neto que vimos que
éste es igual al cambio en el momento
pusimos los valores y encontramos
nuestra velocidad final nuestra
velocidad final después de 9 segundos